[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction voici
lé titre de ce 7 février rouler dans un
véhicule autonome ce sera bientôt
possible à faire ça et l'institut de
transition énergétique pour le véhicule
décarboné communicants vd com lance un
projet européen sur ce thème est les
vacances se poursuivent et à guyancourt
les enfants sont invités à réaliser des
costumes avec du carton ou du papier
crépon nous irons voir le travail de ces
artistes en herbe à la maison de
quartier auguste renoir et puis comme
chaque mardi nous partons à la rencontre
des yvelinois aujourd'hui vous
découvrirez l'histoire de daniel
convenance est un artiste qui trouve sa
force de vivre au quotidien dans la
peinture
on commence cette édition avec du sport
une fois n'est pas coutume avec du
handball est c'est officiel un match de
d1 féminine va être organisée le 25 mars
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
l'annoncé a été faite ce mardi
après-midi dans la structure ici paris
va affronter à cette occasion le club de
brest pour un choc entre les deux
équipes co leader du championnat
objectif battre le record d'affluence
pour un match de première division et
qui est aujourd'hui de 5000 spectateurs
on écoute l'ailière gauche de l'équipe
parisienne coralie lassource au micro de
michael et demi d'euros bah déjà
j'espère que le record sera atteint en
tant que joueuse bas c'est une énorme
c'est un énorme événement donc
hâte d'y être et en même temps on a un
peu d'appréhension parce qu'on sait
qu'on sera vu par beaucoup de personnes
et on sait qu'il faudra justement faire
une belle prestation
donc on a un peu de tension par rapport
à ça mais il faut qu'on se relâche et
qu'on essaye de donner le meilleur de
nous en fait
et dans l'actualité également cette
manifestation organisée aujourd'hui à
versailles à l'appel de la cgt 150 à 200
personnes qui diront qu'ils ont défilé
entre la gare de versailles chantiers et
le palais de justice pour soutenir trois
agents trois agents de l'inspection du
travail du département trois agents
convoqué devant le tribunal la suite à
une plainte déposée pour tentative de
chantage par l'entreprise en charge de
la collecte des déchets la société sepur
un motif qui est contesté par la cgt
écouter la responsable départementale de
ce secteur
c'est une accusation vraiment faim
fantaisistes et qu'une entreprise
s'adapte comme ça à l'administration
chargée de faire respecter le droit du
travail nous indignent particulièrement
à la société c'est très clairement une
tentative d'intimidation mais comment
connaît la l'inspection du travail un
peu partout en france ces derniers temps
puisque sept des dernières semaines on a
eu des inspecteurs du travail qui ont
connu des insultes racistes des
tentatives d'agression physique ou des
menaces de mort donc c'est des choses
qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
admissibles et l'état bien sûr doit
protéger ses agents et contacté par la
rédaction l'entreprise c'est pure n'a
pas souhaité s'exprimer à ce stade de la
procédure
elle nous en parlions en titre rouler
dans un véhicule autonome ce sera
bientôt possible aversa et l'institut de
transition énergétique pour le véhicule
est décarbonée et communicants aussi
connu sous le nom de vd com lance un
projet européen sur cette thématique en
2018 une première flotte de 15 véhicules
devraient voir le jour les précisions
avec anne-laure l'anguille
auto pilot c'est le nom d'un nouveau
projet européen qui vise à élaborer la
voiture autonome de demain en france
l'institut versailles avait des com a
été sélectionné pour mener les
recherches cinq autres pays européens
sont impliqués dans ce programme d'un
coût de 25 millions d'euros
le but principal du projet c'est de
relever le niveau d'automatismes dans le
véhicule en utilisant un nombre
important d'objets connectés qui vont
permettre de fournir des informations à
levante pour l'environnement fedecom
travaillera sur des renault twizy qui
sont des petits véhicules électriques
son objectif est de pouvoir les rendre
autonomes grâce à ses capteurs et
logiciels embarqués
c'est évidemment l'avenir et d'ailleurs
tous les constructeurs automobiles eux
réfléchissent aujourd'hui ce véhicule
autonome c'est un marché énorme
la ville de versailles a équipé le
centre ville pour que ce véhicule puisse
se déplacer sans conducteur le projet au
tout pilote ne vise pas seulement à
développer des technologies d'autonomie
mais aussi à rendre le véhicule
communicant la voiture autonome va
devoir se connecter pour connaître son
environnement ce soit pour connaître par
exemple des conditions météo
pour connaître les conditions de trafic
pour connaître son environnement on
envisage aussi qu'elle pour interagir
avec les smartphones des piétons des
cyclistes histoire de réduire en partie
le nombre d'accidents de la route d'ici
à 2018 et l'ambition de bd comme et de
mettre au point 15 renault twizy
autonome et communicante
elles seront dans un premier temps
destiné au transport de touristes autour
du château de versailles
mais les recherches se poursuivront il y
a des princes technique et aussi des
freins financiers
aujourd'hui ce sont des voitures de
démonstration de recherche
on les a bardé de capteurs barre des
deux systèmes
technologique embarqué il est clair que
on ne peut pas médecin dans la voiture
de monsieur tout le monde et la vendons
toujours à un prix raisonnable
le défi faire baisser le coût de toutes
ces technologies afin de rendre le
véhicule autonome accessible au grand
public automobile toujours mais nous
allons faire un bond à travers les
époques à travers le temps le raid 100 %
étudiant 4l trophy sera organisée du 16
au 26 février entre la france et le
maroc plus de 2500 jeunes qui vont
parcourir à cette occasion et 6000 km
est parmi les participants des yvelinois
notamment des élèves de l'école
d'ingénieurs de saint quentin en
yvelines l'estaca une dizaine d' équipes
se sont constituées dans cette école ils
sont actuellement en train de se
préparer pour le grand départ le
reportage signé michael et demi d'euros
et mathilde demi etienne caux les 20 ans
originaire du chéné n'est pas mécanicien
d'un futur participant au 4l trophy un
raid 100 pour 100 étudiants entre la
france et le maroc
cet élève de l'école d'ingénieurs estaca
prendra le départ de cette 20e édition
avec son ami depuis dix ans killian
hennebelle pour participer c'est tim ils
auront été nécessaires pour financer les
frais d'inscription à la préparation du
véhicule
en parallèle les deux étudiants dû
préparer la fameuse 4l pendant plusieurs
semaines ça soit sur le sponsoring on ya
passé plusieurs mois et la mécanique on
me l'a toujours quelque chose qui on
démonte une pièce est celle d'à côté qui
va casser donc beaucoup beaucoup de
temps tout le monde peut y aller si on
se fait préparer la voiture mais
généralement recommandés notions de
mécanique parce qu'une 4l sa tombent
souvent en panne
moi personnellement je connaissais pas
grand chose avant de commencer on
apprend sur le tas mais on a beaucoup
d'équipages qui nous forme aussi pendant
leur périple les deux acolytes
embarqueront dans leurs coffres entre
les boîtes à outils des fournitures
scolaires les distribueront tout au long
du parcours en partenariat avec
l'association enfants du désert
la structure permet la scolarisation
d'enfants marocains pour les collecter
les étudiants ont fait des actions de
sensibilisation on a fait une première
organisation avec une école à versailles
on a donné des cours de
l'histoire de la voiture et des
mécaniques et des enfants cm1 pour avoir
des fournitures des parents et on a fait
ça une école il ya 50 ans sur le plan
sportif les rétros pilotes membres de
l'association estac hatrel ne se sont
pas fixé d'objectif et veulent terminer
le plus haut possible
pour cela ils devront batailler face à
2700 pilote le but en fait ce pas une
course de vitesse et une course ou faire
le moins de kilomètres possibles donc ça
va être vraiment à l'orientation et on
va se prendre au challenge je pense
qu'il n'ya pas besoin d'elle vite mais
voilà brême dès la 4' en entier ce sera
déjà une grande victoire
le 4l trophy se déroulera du 16 au 26
février le départ sera donné depuis
biarritz cette année plus d'une dizaine
d'étudiants de l'estaca participeront à
la compétition les vacances scolaires se
poursuivent fabriquer son propre costume
avec du carton du papier crépon le stage
est proposé par la ville de guyancourt à
la maison de quartier auguste renoir
nous sommes allés suivre les premiers
courts reportages machine à coudre
pistolet à colle et ciseaux des outils
que ses enfants utilisent parfois pour
la première fois avec l'aide d'une
costumière ils apprennent à créer leur
propre déguisements les filles décident
leurs robes de princesse j'ai voulu
faire tant que tu que des fleurs et de
deux couleurs bleu et rouge
j'aime bien les français j'aime bien fin
du plateau l'âge je voulais faire ce
couleurs loeb ce que je faisais
soit que ça vient de faire du bureau
après du rocher c'était la première fois
six utiliser la machine à perdre et
papier crépon et tissus deviendront une
robe agrémentée de fleurs du côté
garçons célian 70 sera un robot il
s'applique à coller les cheveux sur son
casque en carton ondulé un apprentissage
des différents matériaux et surtout de
l'autonomie de la manipulation de la
manipulation encore de la manipulation
et surtout des coupes et piqué la
machine ça il se pique à la machine le
papier crépon donc ça aussi c'est
important que les enfants puissent le
faire il ya une partie où j'abandonne
une fois qu'ils ont une petite
initiation ils se repèrent vite les
enfants suis pas inquiète
point d'orgue de ce stage de quatre
jours un défilé pour dévoiler son
costume aux parents d'autres ateliers
sont proposés par guyancourt durant
toutes les vacances
[Musique]
comme chaque mardi notre portrait
hebdomadaire et cette semaine nous
partons à versailles rencontré daniel
convenance et un artiste un peu
particulier un problème de santé
elle a poussé à apprendre le pinceau
depuis maintenant 24 ans il peint des
arbres au bitume pour se prouver tout
simplement qu'il est encore vivant
de tout temps la naissance à l'arbre à
la mort
les hommes ou louer avec cloud les
essences et mais sérieuse en relation
l'arbre source d'inspiration de daniel
convenant une passion de la peinture de
toujours devenue vitale
en 1993 un accident vasculaire cérébral
paralyse entièrement tout le côté droit
de son corps
la peinture l'aide alors à s'exprimer
donc je suis entré dans la dans le trône
armes pourquoi le tronc tout simplement
parce que c'est le trait d'union entre
les racines si des allées maison où
j'étais et le feuillage vers la lumière
où j'espère arriver c'était pour moi
à prouver aux autres que d'agrément
marché c'est comme on l'a été pendant
des heures de peinture le jour la nuit
sans cesse après 24 ans de pratiquer un
passage par les beaux-arts par pont-aven
il revient dans les yvelines
il y a dix ans il se met à peindre avec
du bitume
j'ai fait un essai je me suis rendu
compte que c'était c'était rapide
j'étais touché par la profondeur qu'une
oie très très chaud très profond
le but c'est tout est aussi le leçons du
temps aussi parce que le bitume
ça vient du putois le pétrole lui même
ça vient des taux un désert tout ça donc
ça ça en retour à la naissance une
renaissance qu'il présente assez vite un
premier tableau exposé à paris une
soixantaine à guyancourt
une vingtaine d'années plus tôt ses
oeuvres sont toutes autres celle ci a
quand même une mairie un petit bout et
ça ça ne peut que ça représente ma main
est ce que vous êtes droitier et ses
membres à droite c'est de st pauli 2 me
sur ses mains nouées parce que j'étais
parisé par contre des ressorts c'est
encore dur en sauvant la tête
le figuratif et la peinture à l'huile
sont ses premières amours
jusqu'à sa découverte de fabienne
verdier une artiste abstraite dont la
spiritualité fait écho à celle de daniel
covenants des croyances des espoirs des
rêves du feu important c'est le produit
jeunes sur la toile parce que ça vient
de moi même c'est dès ce n'est pas comme
un figuratif ou où on fait quelque chose
qu'on voit mais ça ça vient des tripes
et c'est la fin de ce journal rendez
vous demain aux horaires habituels pour
une toute nouvelle édition les replays
sur notre site internet et sur notre
application mobile très belle soirée
[Musique]